yes because there was a chapel there and
for whatever reason the chapel
captivated us I think because the
building if I remember was round there's
there were no statues which coming from
Saint Mary's in Cambridge you had
statues everywhere so it was just kind
of an odd place to go and we did find
out where the cafeteria was and
sometimes we could go in and get free
sandwiches depending on who was working
the cafeteria I did them as kids we
would want to throw these buildings and
as I walked down the Carter to come to
this room that's the memory I have of
MIT those buildings with all the
concrete walls and all the pipes in the
ceiling that's how I thought of it for
many many years you know it's just you
know like very strongly built buildings
like a fortress but but for us we were
kids MIT was just like you know some
other play we'd find places to play
stickball and tag football long as you
didn't get kicked out by security that's
kind of what you did one time we were
actually allowed to go and they taught
us fencing so as young kids you know we
were able to put on the mask and and use
the swords and do some fencing to which
I thought was you know great no I used
to like the smells in l a-- the
chemicals and you know you go down the
hallways and you smell the different
chemicals and you put your head all day
and the other place was when i use the
welding where they used to make all
different objects i used to like to
stick my head in there and see them
welding yeah i used to go and look at
the ship's they had some model ships
when you went to one of the side doors
and would always go and look at the
model ships i don't know if they were
built by people from MIT but we'd look
at this and all just walking up those
steps and turning around and looking
back you know looking back across the
campus and you felt important